hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday September 3rd 2018 what's
going on how are ya oh happy Labor Day
to you happy [ __ ] Labor Day to you
[Music]
happy [ __ ] Labor Day you cubicle
dwelling car
happy [ __ ] Labor Day to you how many
[ __ ] podcasts are out there wishing
you a happy Labor Day with an original
song huh am I gonna get sued for saying
that in the podcasting world in the
podcasting stratosphere what are you
guys doing today on Labor Day what the
[ __ ] is Labor Day anyways does this have
something to do with the troops how hard
they're working right and you're not
doing [ __ ] cuz you're not wearing a
uniform right how you [ __ ] civilian
piece of [ __ ] don't you love how that's
the vibe now how about a round of
applause for our troops hey lol what's
the rest of us paying the [ __ ] taxes
you [ __ ] to this goddamn field trip
over there that's never gonna [ __ ]
end until what we bankrupt the whole
[ __ ] thing and five [ __ ] have all
the money huh how about a round of
applause for us you rich [ __ ] and
leaving us with the [ __ ] tab can I
get on the plane first every once in a
while you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright Labor Day Labor Day [ __ ]
meaning Labor Day is a public holiday or
day of festivities held in honor of
working people in the United States and
Canada
well the saying about your wife is it on
the first Monday in September and in
many countries on May 1st why do we
always have to be different over here
you know the whole [ __ ] world's on
the metric system no [ __ ] world is
celebrating Labor Day on May 1st not
America now we're on standard September
1st the rest of the world respecting the
summer or at least the spring is your
[ __ ] day off at the end of the
goddamn summer how many like we got to
pack up the water skis hey buddy you
know that's about the ninth [ __ ]
negative thing you said about the United
States of America I got one for you I
got a [ __ ] day off why don't you pack
your [ __ ] up get the [ __ ] out see how
you like it
and some other [ __ ] land [ __ ]
mosquitoes the size of your [ __ ]
freckled bald head you [ __ ] orange
[ __ ] I got a good [ __ ] mind
- get out of my truck and going in show
you what's what happy Labor Day dear
America all you [ __ ] wine and crying
[ __ ] snowflakes out there bitching
about global warming you want to see
warming how about my [ __ ] nuts
[ __ ]
I'm a goddamn coal miner you understand
me I'm a coal miner in 2018 why the [ __ ]
what I want to go out learn about solar
power when I can continue doing a
[ __ ] job it's not so late I don't
give a [ __ ] if I'm digging in a national
park stepping on a [ __ ] bald eagle
[ __ ] head alright if that's going to
put spam on my [ __ ] table I'm going
to do it and there's some orange to play
wearing [ __ ] with a goddamn red
tie down whose [ __ ] knees gonna do it
for me and god damn and I'm gonna vote
for dear America um does he always
wonder what my neighbors think you know
how many people live in that house in
are any of them in a good mood oh Jesus
so it's Labor Day now let me ask you a
question since it's a [ __ ] day off
right does your wife give you the day
off
huh or does she want you to run around
and do a bunch of goddamn jobs that need
to be done while she stays in the house
doing god-knows-what
right I was hoping we could get those
boxes there is that what you were hoping
well
God gave you a couple arms in a back
start lifting there sweetheart
he's [ __ ] ladies I swear to God it
can you can you ever just sit out what
is it couch for in their world other
than to throw too many [ __ ] pillows
on it so you can't even [ __ ] sit down
and the second it's like they know the
second you [ __ ] goddamn assets the
couch and your heads on the pillow and
you grab the remote to watch a little
cough sorry I am in a mood I'm actually
a happy married guy I don't know why I'm
doing this I'm just trying to make you
guys laugh alright cuz I've been in
those relationship alright my wife
school is [ __ ] though you know the other
night I was hanging out right smoking a
seat oh no I wasn't supposed to hang out
I ended up just [ __ ] bartnik called
me up and we ended up hanging out and
she's like you know she sent me the
usual text where are you and I was like
I'm down the comedy store I'm smoking a
cigar some buddies of mine we did a spot
sorry and she goes she goes now hang out
with your friends have a good time and I
texted her back best wife alright
you can't complain if your wife does
that once a [ __ ] year you you got a
gym you know and my wife consistently
does that unless you know what two three
you know the next night when I went out
again I took a little four day vacation
is what I did here as I stayed on my
diet by the way I had a couple little
missteps here there but generally
speaking him I'm drinking a little
[ __ ] smoothie here you know I don't
know what I'm doing I gotta add some
cardio but you know stuff that I got
that [ __ ] [ __ ] bit out of me by some
goddamn bugs I don't know where they
always go after my left foot you know
I'm like the [ __ ] Daniel day-lewis of
bug bikes my left foot they just go
after it right now it is on you know
I literally have to put like some that
oxy 10 on it and then I got to put a saw
on it like so I won't scratch it like
you know when you put a [ __ ] the
goddamn eye someone said chandelier a
[ __ ] lampshade over a dog's [ __ ]
you know so you can't turn around by
itself the problem is that's why I
should I should stick a [ __ ] one of
the lampshades on my on my ankle but the
problem is I'm a goddamn human being
made in the image of our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ so I have the ability to
figure out how to take off said
lampshade and start scratching the [ __ ]
out of my ankle it was so bad the other
night actually woke me up
like nothing could touch it it was on
[ __ ] fire and these are next level
these are next level global warming
[ __ ] mosquitoes all right if you got
a pair of jeans on or dungarees as they
used to be called they'll bite right
through them they don't give a [ __ ] you
know I wish there could be some assassin
[ __ ] mosquitoes right and rather than
just bitin regular old [ __ ] people
and giving a malaria in that [ __ ] like
it just [ __ ] just go find one of
those Bilderberg meetings they just find
who the [ __ ] is in front of all this
goddamned madness sorry guys I don't
know this is why I don't watch the
[ __ ] news yeah just going 100 million
[ __ ] miles an hour into the brick
wall and all these [ __ ] rich people
think that somehow they're gonna have a
parachute and I guess what the rest of
us are all gonna die is that what it is
Oh bill come on it's a holiday all right
all right let's talk football here let's
talk football bum bum bum bum bum
how about those Red Sox lost of the
White Sox last night eight to nothing
for the first time we're actually kind
of playing like 500 ball and I think
it's a great thing I don't want to go to
the [ __ ] playoffs not knowing what
losing feels like like wait what's this
are the wheels coming off I want two
more be like oh yeah
we got out of this all right sales still
on the disabled list as far as I know
and I don't know if price has his pitch
since he got hit by that comeback liner
off his wrist x-rays were negative we're
doing further [ __ ] studies so we
shall see we'll see what's going to
happen last I saw the Astros the team to
beat the defending World Series
champions getting zero respect out there
in Houston you know you would think that
the baseball team was as fat as the
average person in Houston and don't even
[ __ ] wrinkle you goddamn snout up at
me if you [ __ ] live in Houston you
guys went back-to-back you had a goddamn
dynasty of being [ __ ] nominated a
winning the fattest city in the United
States of America
alright and this is the fattest [ __ ]
country evidently okay you are you are a
fat person's fatty Houston down there
[ __ ] barbecue and everything aren't
you huh
do you know I was just actually actually
just in Houston there there is not a Jew
stand that entire city lettuce is
illegal this is this is a u.s. city okay
now are you wondering why they had that
Biblical Flood down there maybe God was
like this is a level of sloth that I
have never seen see that's why there's
never a flood out here in Hollywood okay
because we are so righteous we are so
living day to day in his image in his
word I wanted you all right now I want
you to close your eyes I want you close
your eyes right now and just know that
Jesus he wants you to live in Hollywood
he wants you to go there he wants you to
do some coke he wants you get a girl
and try to [ __ ] her friend try to get
both into [ __ ] you at the same time he
wants that um sorry that was my Joel
Olsteen that's why he didn't open the
goddamn doors well known that flood
[ __ ] came in like I don't have enough
[ __ ] what am I [ __ ] Jesus gonna
keep pulling out [ __ ] barbecued fish
for these people
III don't I simply do not have enough
way to sustain this it's gonna be a riot
thinkin they gonna rip up my blue carpet
he was content to let those fatties just
float right by the arena uh well you
know what I would have done I would have
put some [ __ ] moorings since I would
you call this things he get dock a boat
to I would have thrown some rope out
there and just had those fatties [ __ ]
you know a bunch of dinghies until the
water came down I mean what was Joel
Olsteen supposed to do okay Joel
Osteen's in shape he lives in Houston
you know why that is it's a miracle I
tell you I saw the image of a skinny
Joel Osteen and my pop-tart the other
day when I was in downtown Houston you
ever take two pop-tarts you heat them up
and you stick a glazed donut in the
middle of it
of course you don't you don't live in
Houston you ain't about this laughs um I
had a drink smoothies more before I do a
podcast I have incredible energy and a
new level of disrespect for a lot of
things dude my [ __ ] foot my [ __ ]
foot is driving me nuts and then I got I
got a bug bite on the back of my arm and
then I got another one on my lower back
like just to the right of where a [ __ ]
stamp would be did I ever tell you guys
I was dumb enough to get one of those in
the 90s I did I got a Boston Bruins
stamp [ __ ] you know and it said real
men wear black and I had that right
above my ass and I had to I had to work
so hard I'm sorry in stand up to finally
be able to afford enough money to begin
my laser treatments to remove it I know
a lot of you probably always wondered
why I never wore a half-shirt on stage
well that is why okay I mean I guess my
big fault is that I'm a hockey fan okay
there I said it
you guys watch any college football
yesterday
how about college football just taking
over this weekend the way the NFL does
towards the end of the year the NFL
doesn't give a [ __ ] that you got
Christmas shopping to do they don't care
that you got your Jewish and you gotta
buy [ __ ] was it eight gifts nine gifts
for each [ __ ] person right is that
candle [ __ ] goes candle number one
what do you got well how do you do it
Jewish people do you do do you build do
you build up the gifts that's why you
got to do it right you got to start with
the weakest thing you got right what do
you got a pair of socks you know and you
just gradually build the whole outfit up
just shopping for Kwanzaa right the NFL
does not give a [ __ ] come the end of the
year they like we own all the weekends
we're taking all the [ __ ] money
alright we're showing games on Saturday
that we thought were gonna matter but
don't we're kicking off this Thursday
there's Thursday the NFL season is back
ladies and gentlemen
NFL football is back okay
and for the next 17 [ __ ] weeks with
the by week I have a [ __ ] long the
[ __ ] season is now the regular season
okay I like to think that this country
can set aside all of the issues that
Angus down and we can lose ourselves in
the bread and circus that is
professional football and when does it
start bill Oh what would it'll put it on
it starts Thursday night Thursday night
with yellow defending Super Bowl
champions the Philadelphia Eagles did
you ever think you'd ever hear that in
your [ __ ] life people of Philadelphia
you know you didn't don't even act like
you did right where the [ __ ] am i you
guys are playing the dirty Birds down
there and [ __ ] Atlanta it's it's it's
the Battle of the birds this Thursday
night this is the only Thursday game
worth watching for the entire [ __ ]
season Wow
you might not have asked because this is
the only one where the [ __ ] teams
didn't play four days earlier and
they're all banged up yes
the Eagles will be wearing green on
green yes the Falcons will be wearing
I don't know black and red on black and
red it's a whole game for the Eagles
they're probably going to bring the the
the championship flag up there and can
you imagine how many people in the city
of Philadelphia are not going to be able
to time their alcohol intake to when the
flag is going to be raised and they'll
be in that little jail in the Eagle
stadium looking out you know while the
police laughs at them the local cops as
they play Iron Maiden's rhyme in the
Ancient Mariner right somehow it
combined Rime of the Ancient Mariner
with the count amount of Christopher
Moniz looking out the [ __ ] his jail
cell and he could see the ocean you
could see how free you know see the
boats going by and he was just sitting
in there and then later he got a gig on
Sesame Street anyways it starts with the
Eagles and the Falcons now are the
Eagles still celebrating
who am i Patriots playing Tom Brady
coming up one of his great games as a
pro against the Eagles a lot of people
forget that dog broke the [ __ ] ball
he threw for over 500 yards in a Super
Bowl and lost okay
now unless the Patriots go to the Super
Bowl again this year you tell me when
the [ __ ] that's ever gonna happen again
everybody talking about Joe DiMaggio no
oh 56-game hitting streak whatever
anybody can [ __ ] do that 56-game
hitting streak is it's pretty goddamn it
impressive you know to the point they
literally were writing songs joltin Joe
DiMaggio whatever they were doing right
president was paying attention did
anybody write a [ __ ] song with Tom
Brady threw for 500 [ __ ] yards and a
goddamn Super Bowl people have thrown
for half that much smoked a cigar and
paraded around with the feeling he threw
enough yards to win two [ __ ] trophies
in one game and the man lost so
everybody's sitting around going how
again Tom keep doing it he's [ __ ] old
and blah blah blah blah blah okay and
I'm sitting over here with no more hair
left on top of my head to pull out going
the problem is not Tommy I would say
it's our defense that's why I would say
that that was the [ __ ] problem that
was such a [ __ ] weird game I would
love to go back and watch it at some
point and just try to figure out how
there was only [ __ ] two punts or
three punts the whole [ __ ] game the
weirdest goddamn game I've ever seen in
my life it's like both offenses showed
up the play and the eat and the [ __ ]
defense was just like this is a Super
Bowl I just can't get comfortable what
else we could we got the Bengals or the
bangles as is Pulver's he calls them the
bangles calls him the girl group there
and he calls the girl group the Bengals
okay but Paul virzi he
marches to the beat of his own drummer
is playing the Colts Andrew Luck and I'm
gonna tell you something right now I'm
tasting right now by Andrew Luck all
right if you're [ __ ] sittin there
right and life keeps kicking you in the
dick and you landed face down in the
dust you know and you just don't want to
get up anymore watch Andrew Luck take a
[ __ ] hit he doesn't give a [ __ ] gets
up he congratulate Sag a great job man
I'll probably be feeling that in my
early 50s congratulations
see on the next play I love that guy
this is me actually saying something
positive about the Indianapolis Colts as
much as I hate Jim Irsay all right
Andrew Luck the way he conducts himself
out there with such [ __ ] class yeah I
say it actually actually transcends the
fact that he takes a paycheck from that
corrupt piece of [ __ ] that flim-flam the
boss hogg or the [ __ ] NFL anyways the
bills are playing the Ravens this is
what I gotta be asking my I'm a Buffalo
Bills fan and I got my face and a plate
full of [ __ ] wings over at Anchor Bar
our [ __ ] Duffy's whatever the [ __ ]
you're supposed to go I gotta be asking
myself is this the year where the bills
for the finally returned to their AFC
Championship winning glory do the bills
finally get back to their peak going to
a Super Bowl sorry you know I'm gonna
get people in the AFC East a lot of [ __ ]
the Buccaneers and the Saints Drew Brees
by the way not a lot of people realize
this guy he's second all-time I think
he's throwing for more yards than Tom
Brady and nobody pays attention to him
who was who's kidding who he's not
dreamy like Tom Brady he's not as tall
as Tom Brady you know supermodels are
not knocking on his door he is a regular
Joe he's a family man you know and he's
down there and in a [ __ ] city that
even the devil is even scared to go to
and he is gone he's been able to
maintain the [ __ ] values that he was
he was brought up and I would say that
is actually more impressive to me than
actually the amount of yards he's thrown
in his career we're taking collars
Patriots are playing the Texans right
and that [ __ ] insane quarterbacks
coming but I already forgot everybody's
names was that kid from Louisville
so Clem's and I know what the [ __ ] he's
from but I know he's amazing and JJ
Watts his back
so this should be an early test for
these delinquent payments the 49ers
versus the Vikings I don't know what's
going on over there okay his Kaepernick
still kneeling on the ground
Kaepernick doesn't have a gig the
Vikings the Vikings who are at their
peak right now doing what they do coming
close [ __ ] it up waiting to the next
season and they are on the rook and they
finally can they finally turn the
[ __ ] corner what else what else is
going on the Giants are looking good
they got that maniac running back from
[ __ ] Penn State they're playing the
Jaguars the Browns they got that [ __ ]
dude from Oklahoma right oh that the
other the guy on TV said was undrafted
and he went on his [ __ ] show with an
undrafted will short they got this kid a
little bit of the Cleveland Browns
playing the Steelers right out of the
gate Jesus Christ those two cities don't
even get a chance to put that [ __ ]
fakes up I cannot [ __ ] wait I am
taping all of these games and your Los
Angeles Rams
versus the Oakland soon to be Las Vegas
Raiders I mean how great a [ __ ] game
is that gonna be that's the game right
there that's the game of the week right
there Rams first Raiders as far as I'm
concerned that's the one I want to see
all the 49ers have what's his face
Seattle's Richard Sherman
they got him coming back from the
[ __ ] dreaded Achilles tendon injury
see what he can do for the 49ers you
know what I mean
all right there you go so good luck to
all you guys unless you're playing the
Patriots and now let's talk college
football how great was the college
football you know they were smart enough
to not have all those cupcake games to
begin in a year I mean when I was
growing up like September was a joke you
get your football kid from your bookie
and what would they be saying it would
be just like Nebraska would be favored
by 59 against like Kent State and you'd
take Kent State and then like they would
be up like like [ __ ] 35 to nothing at
the half and you're like then they would
cover anyways
I watched my LSU my adopted LSU Tigers
against the Miami Hurricanes and a good
friend of mine is a huge Miami hurricane
fan to the point that I actually root
for the Miami Hurricanes because I'm
friends with him not that I was ever a
hurricane fan I wasn't so he was playing
my adopted LSU Tigers his team was
playing my team so I texted him before
the game I said the Miami tropical
depression you know like when they think
it's going to be a hurricane and then
they downgraded to a tropical storm with
the downgrade of tropical storm his
tropical depression I believe according
to the weather that I looked up so he's
like [ __ ] you man
so we board have a better round of
drinks some cigar came in [ __ ]
remember and I gotta tell you right now
I thought you know LSU the entire time
I've been a fan of these guys since like
2008 when I moved out here 2007-2008 so
2007 when I came out to LA and I
actually had time to watch college
football and I'd like Les Myers and how
he would go for it on fourth down and
trick plays and all that [ __ ] now you
know and I just always let me just jump
on the Alabama bandwagon isn't it
amazing that they're still at the peak
10 years later there's still the team to
beat so I was like I'm gonna go with
these guys so I've been watching them
for 10 years and for 10 years we have
not had a [ __ ] quarterback they were
doing that awful thing like that old
school college football thing where it
was just like this is a running down put
in the black quarterback this is a
passing down put in the white
quarterback they were doing that [ __ ] in
the 2000s right and then I think they're
their all-time rushing leader was their
quarterback you know which is not a good
stat they've had these beasts at defense
they actually had Odell Beckham at one
point my buddy was saying like what a
[ __ ] waste they had nobody to throw
it to throw it to him so I'm watching
the game yesterday and this kid jobber
oh well I guess transfers from from some
other college I was losing my mind
watching this guy I like this guy's a
[ __ ] quarterback you know people
getting in his face giving him [ __ ] he's
giving him [ __ ] back he's [ __ ] he's
reading the Blitz you know he's he was
doing all this type of [ __ ] and I was
all excited and that was like this guy's
got to have like 250 yards he only had
one hundred one hundred and forty four
that's how much the QB position has
suffered while I've been watching these
guys that I was excited that there was a
guy in the middle of the third quarter
had 144 yards passing and their new
coach I hope I say his name right edie
or gerund or Geron I don't know how to
say his name but all I know is he's he's
got that by you [ __ ] accent and he
sounds like [ __ ] Hulk Hogan he sounds
like he's doing a wrestling promo I was
waiting for me let me tell you something
brother I'll try to get you a clip of
him and he flips out and screams and
yells at the players and that reminds me
of what a football coach was when I was
a kid LSU for the most part just handled
25th ranked LSU just handled eighth
ranked Miami tropical depression Miami
Hurricanes and but in typical LSU
fashion they still scared me towards the
end when all of a sudden Miami started
coming back and then it was just like it
was 33 to 17 with six minutes left and
Miami stopped him again I'm like they
are too
and to two-point conversions touchdown
two-point conversions away from tying
this [ __ ] game only LS you could make
me this nervous after being up like 33
to 10 or some [ __ ] like that
but they held on they won and all of
that so I am excited I know it's the
first week of the season before all you
negative consult they're gonna be [ __ ]
you know you know baby money was all
over overrated much you know like that's
some sort of like people just hate
people being excited Oh what are you
happy about something how can I [ __ ]
[ __ ] all over this
anyways let's let's do some ad reads
here on Labor Day to you oh just in time
for [ __ ] football season uh now
remember people you got a gamble
responsibly what I love about these guys
is these guys to not hide behind the
fact that they are a gambling site like
some of those other ones way back in the
day like this is this is a game of skill
alright my bookie huh
bookie they're proud you know like like
a [ __ ] fat actress going up accept an
award being like I know I look good
right same thing they're being brave
right now um my bookie you know ever
since I this podcast people have been
asking me for advice I don't know why
ask me what team to bet on the truth is
I don't know who's going to win but if
you think you know you got a chance you
got to check out my bookie I could have
done in a way but it the truth is I
don't know who's gonna win but if you
think you know you got to check out my
bookie remember who you're betting on is
just as important as who you're betting
with that's why I always tell people to
bet with my bookie
I didn't know I did that trust me guys
they are your best bet this season
they've been in business for years have
been getting great reviews online and
their mobile site is easy to use okay
what your paycheck on a team this is the
website to do it I would only recommend
a service to my listeners that that's
been good to me that's why I'm urging
you to make your way to my bookie you
win they pay that's how it works why are
they making this sound loud like that
[ __ ] doing some Cub Scout [ __ ] listen
you [ __ ] degenerate gamblers here's a
[ __ ] website that's not a shame that
they're gonna try and take your [ __ ]
money you think you can beat him
go to the [ __ ] website they have in
game living live BET live betting Jesus
bill the most rewarding player perks in
the business and for you fan and see
guys out there man all you guys on
unicorns betting on [ __ ] football you
can even bet the over-under on how many
fantasy points a player will score each
game join now and my bookie will match
your deposit dollar for dollar use promo
code BRR be URR to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's my
bookie my B oh okay ie and don't forget
to use the promo code bar when creating
your account to claim up to $1,000 in
free play you play you win you get paid
also you play you lose you don't get
laid
especially if it's your girlfriend's
money so please [ __ ] bet responsibly
I will be calling in tomorrow to my
bookie I believe it's 7 o'clock or 8
o'clock at night Pacific time alright
I'll be calling in with my picks even
though I don't know what the [ __ ]
going I'll make you laugh is what I'll
do alright so if you want to gamble
there's the place to go but to do it
responsibly ok don't don't be getting
[ __ ] crazy
all right frame bridge everybody ok
you've been listening to this show you
heard me talk about frame bridge or at
least read about it they made it super
easy and affordable to frame your
favorite things from at prints and
posters to the travel photos sitting on
your phone here's how it works you know
what I just framed 3 of them from France
in London and we got them sitting right
onto my TV and it looks great it's a
little collage if you will just go to
frame bridge calm and upload your photo
or they'll send you a package to safely
mail it in your
your physical pieces the [ __ ] does that
mean
preview your item online in any frame
style choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers though how about a blue frame
the expert team at frame bridge will
custom frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you'd pay at the framing store their
prices start at just $39 and all
shipping is free plus my listeners will
get 15% off their first order at frame
bridge calm when they use my code Burpee
you are our give your personal
experience using frame bridge I went to
London and I went to Paris France and I
showed my [ __ ] stamp Underpants and I
took a couple of pictures you know with
my wife and our beautiful daughter in
front of the Louvre in front of the
Eiffel Tower right my favorite place to
my favorite cafe do a manual all rules
drama no it's not over there where the
[ __ ] is it I figure what street it's on
and then I took one of me smoking a
cigar with my dad when we were in London
and I just had all of those framed and
that's great
because you know you take all these
great pictures they stay on your phone
and then you know they end up in some
hard drive and then you break up with
somebody you forget the [ __ ] hard
drive
make sure you frame your good ones you
know they're good to look at too you're
like oh that's right there are people in
the world that like me
get started today frame your photos or
send the perfect gift for weddings
birthdays in a special event go to frame
bridge calm and use the promo code bar
you'll save an additional 15% off your
first order just go to frame bridge calm
promo code BER fr AME Bri DGE comm
promote code bar on one of people who
like rob banks ever take selfies with
each other you know this is a joke and
then they boy can't send it to frame
bridge well they wouldn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on they think they were a
Halloween party no matter what you do in
the bathroom stop jerking off
- get ready Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best they have amazing shower
stuff hair styling products toothbrushes
and toothpaste and of course raises and
shave supplies you might shave your
whole body to get ready for a bike race
you might have to shave your whole body
Dollar Shave club's executive razor and
shave can't help you might do your hair
to get ready for your soccer match well
I don't play soccer and I'm [ __ ]
shaped my head here
Boogie's by Dollar Shave Club can help
you get your style right Boogie's huh
the thing is no matter what you do to
get ready Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need and right now you
two get ready with an amazing deal on on
any one of their starter sets like the
daily essentials starters that but you
can't go wrong with any of them head
over to dollarshaveclub.com slash / -
pick up your own DSC starter set for
just 5 bucks after your starter set
product ship at a regular price and make
sure you check out their new video -
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash bar
dollarshaveclub.com slash bar
alright 2 more reads Oh draftkings
everybody oh they're not ashamed anymore
draftkings football returns Thursday
night 1 boo doo doo put it up and huge
cash prizes are up for grabs at
draftkings the leader in one-week
fantasy sports for the season opener
draft kings is hosting a fantasy
football contest that just that's just
$10 to enter and has a a 1 million
dollar top prize all you guys on your
unicorns with your fantasy teams but for
a limited time if you sign up with the
code Barbie you are our draft kings
we'll give you a free entry with your
first deposit single game showdown is
the newest way to play just draft six
players from Thursday's game stay under
the salary cap and see how your team
stacks up against the competition put
your football knowledge to work and you
could win a million bucks while watching
the season
you know I make fun of fantasy guys but
like that's actually really [ __ ] cool
and I'm afraid to [ __ ] do it because
I will become addicted and I'll be like
you guys and stop rooting for teams and
I'll start rooting for players you don't
even have to come in first to be a
winner there are two and a half million
dollars in total prizes which means
thousands of winners download the app or
go to draftkings.com now and use the
code bar to sign up and make your first
deposit where do you do draftkings will
give ya a free shot at a million bucks
this Thursday that's promo core promo
code bar only at draft khun's king's
minimum five dollar deposit eligibility
restrictions apply see draft kings.com
for details and lastly but not leastly
sorry I [ __ ] up the rest of that read
my head was actually I've already made
the burger patties okay now next thing
I'm gonna do him a cup two tomatoes the
lettuce have all the pickles have
everything ready to [ __ ] go and this
year for the first time ever I am going
to do a practice burger just to make
sure my temperature is right to know how
long so for all the people who want a
medium-rare medium well well done all of
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I made my patties small this year I made
him thin all right better than
McDonald's or old school McDonald's not
quite Wendy's all right right in the
[ __ ] wheelhouse because I used to
work I used to work in a this place
called the sable cafe in in Cary North
Carolina I worked there I swear to God
31 years ago I worked there for nine
months and unfortunately the restaurant
was gradually going out of business I
was a busboy and then I became the
busboy and dishwasher and then at one
point I swear to God I was the grill
chef the busboy and the dishwasher as I
took on these extra jobs they would give
me like a 50-cent raise and I was so bad
with math and never dawned on me like
hey minimum wage is 350 an hour and and
and the dishwasher was getting paid 350
an hour and I was getting paid 350 an
hour so you paying two people $7
an hour to do these two jobs and now I'm
doing both jobs that other person
doesn't have a job and I'm only making
$4 an hour then I became the grill chef
tanned I think I was making 475 an hour
of 5 bucks an hour to do 3 [ __ ] jobs
and I would be out there and I would be
I was glassed-in on a mesquite grill
with the chef's hat and underneath my
apron I had the bowtie [ __ ] busboy
outfit it was literally like you know
when Peter Brady had two dates in one
night right and I [ __ ] would duck
down when I saw a table almost done
eating and I would run out there bust
the table run back throw all the dishes
in the dishwasher and then run [ __ ]
back out without washing my hands
there's just food but you still you know
I'm just handling your food and then I
would continue [ __ ] cooking and
that's when I learned that little trick
you know where you know I learned it
this way you put you if you put your you
just touch your thumb to your index
finger and then touch the fleshy part of
your of your hand that connects to your
thumb and you press on that that's rare
then you just move it to your middle
finger that's like medium rare then the
ring fingers well and then the [ __ ]
pinkies well done
now that [ __ ] works provided you did
it all but it all depends on how thick
the patty is and I'll high your [ __ ]
heaters so you got to balance all of
that out so you can use that because
that actually [ __ ] works unless you
heats up too high and your meats too
thick and then you think it's well-done
and all you did was Chiu outside and
inside it's a [ __ ] Friday the 13th so
I'm gonna do that and have myself a
tasty [ __ ] burger before anybody even
arrives I'm gonna have my timer I'm
gonna adjust my [ __ ] heat and I'm
gonna I'm gonna be ready for [ __ ]
Freddie you know what I mean that's
that's my deal here okay that's how I'm
doing and I'm going simple this year
burgers and dogs
[ __ ] you you know
I could get the [ __ ] out this country
I'm not smoking anything I'm not [ __ ]
I'm not doing any of this [ __ ]
burgers and dogs we got potato chips we
have the standard [ __ ] condiments
lettuce tomato pickles ketchup onions
mustard all right no [ __ ] Asian
infused [ __ ] this or
italian-influenced that old Billy ball
game I'm going the [ __ ] I'm going old
school we got cheese what kind of cheese
you want you want the white of the
yellow we don't have any margarine we
have butter I'm toasting the buns unless
you tell me otherwise all right that's
it
can you feel my anxiety all right stamps
calm everybody the US Postal Service is
an important tool for any business
stamps comb is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office I don't know why but I feel like
over annunciated this whole read stamps
calm never closes print postage for
letters or packages at your convenience
24/7 print postage for any mail class
right from your own computer buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and printer they'll send
you a digital scale automatic that
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps com will even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs
no need to lease an expensive expensive
postage meter and there are no long-term
commitments I use stamps.com because
include your personal recommendation
whenever i solutely no negative
references to the post-office oh my god
I wish I could cook a burger for people
at the post office and right now you too
can enjoy stamps to add cam service with
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital
scale go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the
the homepage and type in burr that
stamps dad can enter burr alright that
was my nod to people in the Midwest go
to stamps.com in order there butcher box
speaking of butcher box butcher box pork
and a TC festival that's right the all
things comedy festival is is it's coming
back to Phoenix it's coming back to
Phoenix in October
hey and by the way and I will be there
doing a live podcast this is a pre
[ __ ] promo ok I don't have any dates
yet I'm just letting you know
keep your October open its October
twenty something I believe anyways it's
probably already on sale don't even know
speaking of other things that I need to
promote I did a movie last year called
the front all right and the trailer
starring Hugh Jackman the trailer who's
already getting Oscar Oscar buzz he's
getting Oscar buzz old freckles alright
and I actually made the trailer um do
you realize how much I'm moving up in
the world that I'm actually in the movie
trailer now I'm not saying that if you
drop a piece of popcorn you look down
and kick it under the seat in front of
you that you won't miss me in the
trailer I'm just saying that I am in it
for a with one of the best actors of
today who is getting Oscar buzz repeat
Oscar buzz this weekend I'm gonna be in
some casino north of the hell's in
Sacramento and then the next day I'm
going to the Toronto Film Festival for
the premiere of the front runner
starring Hugh Jackman who's getting
Oscar buzz okay and then and in an other
than the movie was directed by the great
jason reitman by the way if you want to
[ __ ] win an Oscar okay it's starting
to become
work with old freckles here all right
we had to foster winners last year two
or three from from f is for family
[ __ ] Sam Rockwell's want it Allison
Janney want it I think Laura Dern got
like a Golden Globe
I don't watch award shows okay I don't
have time I'm too busy focusing on
things that don't matter like sports and
now we'll look what happens I have about
seven lines in this movie and all of a
sudden not coincidentally Hugh Jackman
is now nominated or now he's getting
Oscar buzz I should say okay and why is
that because he's unbelievably talented
because he puts the work in because he's
a pro maybe maybe but I think more so is
that he had half a scene with me I think
that's what it is see once I go in the
scene and they see what I look like and
where my acting is ech at right Alma
said hack and act at the same time then
whatever you're doing is the other actor
it's just gonna be so [ __ ] elevated
that all of a sudden you're you know
you're gonna be in the running okay and
that's what I bring to Hollywood all
right put your box everybody and the all
things Comedy Festival
oh by the way congratulations to Jason
Reitman and Hugh Jackman for getting all
this great and everybody else that's in
the [ __ ] movie you know for getting
all this awesome reviews which is a very
hard thing to do there's day and age
with all the [ __ ] out there in the
internet it's really difficult to try to
get some sort of positive feedback um
and I'm just happy just to be a small
part of it you know what I mean I'm like
Bill Walton when he joined the Celtics
okay my feet are [ __ ] up I'm just a
happy you know every once in a while
throw it to me and I'll get a couple of
points the crowd will go nuts because I
am on the scoring sheet that that's
that's where I'm it butcher box pork at
the all things Comedy Festival hey Bill
huge fan just writing in to thank you
for the butcher block block plug Oh
listen to this this dude tried the pork
chop that I've been raving about the
Heritage bread [ __ ] pork okay you
talk about the pork chops you talked
about the pork chops and how great they
were so I had to get my hands on my wife
who is an amazing cook
seasoned these chops so well I have to
share it with you
she put extra virgin olive oil on them
and salt and pepper then let them rest
for like 45 minutes look at that I mean
that's about a standard of rub as you
could possibly get that's all you have
to do about a half a teaspoon per chop
then she just cooked them in the oven
for like 25 minutes you said the over
cooked them in the over for like 20 to
25 minutes I'm assuming that meant oven
bill it was the best goddamn pork chop I
ever had I [ __ ] told you he goes when
you get a cheat day try that recipe
thanks again can't wait to see you in
Phoenix in October so I guess the the
tickets are already on sale yeah guys
I'm telling you man who [ __ ] knew
that there was a purebred [ __ ] pig
out there which bloodlines can be traced
back to the original white people the og
Whitey's over there in Europe I'm
telling you I did mine differently I
took out a black skillet and I got that
heat going right and I just I I forget
what I I don't even know what I put on
the [ __ ] thing I probably didn't know
and me German Irish guy that I am i
seared both sides and then I finished it
in the oven and then I brought it out
and I did a like a rosemary butter bath
oh I mean I didn't even need a [ __ ]
side who's everybody I took I was just
punching the [ __ ] table it was it's
it's that [ __ ] good all right if
you're a kind of warrior you got to get
the [ __ ] Heritage bread boy they're
not even paying me for this this is all
[ __ ] goodies all right urban mayor
although that's a real slick way to get
some [ __ ] advertising in for free be
somebody that [ __ ] writes in with
their own experience Urban Meyer
or mayor Howard spell that's John Mayer
but it's Urban Meyer is it John Mayer
hey Billy beluga whale what are your
thoughts about Urban Meyer and the OSU
scandal do you think he should have been
fired oh you know I stopped falling that
he got fired over that what the [ __ ] was
this is this jerseys again urban mayor
fired reason there we go
pom pom pom pom bow - why is Urban Meyer
he suspended doesn't say oh he's not
fired he's suspended I was gonna say
Jason law head would have been [ __ ]
tweeting all in capitals at at the whole
[ __ ] world maybe he was
why is Urban Meyer suspended here's the
short and the long answer Nile state
suspended Urban Meyer for the first
three games of Ohio State's 2018 season
who the [ __ ] are they playing [ __ ] had
you this is this is the non suspension
suspension he's Miz's the Buckeye season
opener against Oregon State
they likely blowout win four weeks two
and three against Rutgers another likely
blowout win and TCU a tougher game and a
trip to Texas TCU is kind of fell off
well what happened to TCU come on mayor
can coach during the week before sitting
out the game itself
offensive coordinator Ryan Day is acting
head coach while Meyer is out yeah and
he has a headset on the whole game gee
who the [ __ ] you think he's talking to
the short reason for the head coaches
suspension school commission
investigation decided he mishandled
domestic abuse allegations against his
former receivers coach Zack Smith oh
this is a little more serious but they
didn't think is it bill is it a little
more serious than [ __ ] players
selling their own Jersey but they didn't
think mayor's conduct was egregious
enough to merit firing one of the most
successful coaches in college football
history subtext hey it was only one
broad all right we got a national
championship with this guy below is the
longer reason a recap for the details
Smith's now ex-wife Courtney Smith has
repeatedly accused him of domestic
violence going back to 2009 so how does
this fall on
Urban Meyer he's supposed to be a
[ __ ] cop to 2009 zachsmith then a
staffer under Meyer at Florida went to a
party at Myers house Smith came home
with the woman co-worker who had been
drinking and planned to have her stay on
Smith's couch according to investigation
it sounds like a standard party they
said Courtney Smith strenuously objected
and drove the woman to her home that
began a disagreement
Courtney's called 911 threw her against
the wall
police arrested Zack for aggravated
battery and later dropped the charge
Meyer says Zack and Courtney met with
him at his Florida office and told him
Zacks arrest was based on false
information Courtney gave to the police
yeah in other words she told the [ __ ]
truth and then when they [ __ ] sobered
up or calmed down they were like this
could cost us a lot of money don't do it
again and we'll say that I lied Courtney
denies that she attended that meeting
and Zack also recalled two OSU's
investigators that she wasn't there okay
so he sounds like he's lying to the
investigative team Courtney Smith denied
recanting her allegations she has never
walked back any allegations in public
interviews either all right no charges
were ultimately filed against Zack for
the 2009 incident yeah because they were
working for a big University when Meyer
well how does this it go on Urban Meyer
mayor Meyer hired him at Ohio State in
2011 a university background check
didn't turn up an arrest
Meyer didn't tell anyone else at Ohio
State about it because he told
investigators weren't filed and he
didn't think Zack had actually committed
any domestic violence between October
and November 2050 and and what's the
show that he even saw this [ __ ] in
October and November 2015 police twice
went to Cortese home to investigate
abuse allegations against Zack do this
one heal so it's like we just [ __ ]
break up already
that year Courtney texted with mayor's
wife Shelly about Zack Shelley expects
sympathy and fear for Courtney and in
her own message and Courtney has said
he told her she didn't formed the head
coach about Courtney's allegations yeah
but she could have been lying you know
both mayor Meyer maintained to OSU
investigated that Shelly never did
inform urban about the text message but
Meyer has acknowledged both in a public
statement early August and to
investigators that he did know of an
allegation in 2015 I don't understand so
what so he knows about it so call the
[ __ ] cops like I don't understand
like why this is on the football [ __ ]
program they aren't they are not the
cops they are not judges they are not
juries this whole [ __ ] thing now
we're like the judge in the jury and all
of that [ __ ] is now on social media and
all of this [ __ ] it's it's [ __ ] I
don't I don't get this it's like if he
[ __ ] did something call the cops the
cops go there they [ __ ] arrest them
any [ __ ] goes to jail I don't
understand how the cops go there i
recanted it no you didn't all right we
dropped the [ __ ] charges but then the
cops dropped the charges
but then the school is supposed to go no
but you're still [ __ ] guilty I don't
know I mean unless he was there and saw
him doing that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is he
supposed to do
this is why you have cops this is why
the cops don't coach a football team I
don't know I have no idea I don't I
don't get that I get that if the
university fired that guy you know I
don't get why urban mayor Meyer why that
guy gets dragged into the [ __ ] I mean if
he was beating the [ __ ] out of her at a
[ __ ] football practice then I guess
urban was they're gonna settle down
settle down
nothing to see here and I guess he
implicated himself like that I mean I
don't you know
I mean the diseases these are [ __ ]
adults here
that guy knows he's not supposed to be
beating up his [ __ ] wife he's an
adult so he should pay the [ __ ] price
I don't get why this guy has to now you
don't I mean when some gold-digging
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know takes some guy's
house does she go to jail does she lose
her job does her friend that knew she
was a gold-digging [ __ ] does she then
lose her [ __ ] position in the [ __ ]
world I don't get it's just it's just
like it's a [ __ ] one-sided street
here if a guy does something to a woman
that he shouldn't be doing not only is
he gonna get punished now everybody
around him is gonna get [ __ ] punished
but if a woman does something to a guy
yeah it's alright everything's [ __ ]
fine it's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what I
say I think it's [ __ ] [ __ ] if
they were doing this on both sides of
the [ __ ] fence if you could somehow
prove that this guy actually [ __ ]
knew this [ __ ] granted I'm just going
off of one website here alright from
what I read on the Internet which
doesn't mean [ __ ] now why do you guys
ask me these [ __ ] questions alright
dancing hey Bill I'm a 16 year old kid
for a Minnesota Minnesota and I'm
starting at my junior year in high
school this week I'm not a loser and I'm
not the coolest kid either I'm right
yeah you go you're in the middle that's
where I was I feel like I'm being held
back by my inability to dance what do
you go to Fame high school it's not that
I don't have rhythm I play three
instruments my band leader told me to
dance like I was playing in instruments
the problem is I never know what to do
with my hands and I can't exactly be
playing air sacks at dances this year I
really don't care that much it's just
that I know I can dance but I haven't
figured out moves yet well then start
dancing there buddy go on the [ __ ]
Internet I'll go on the internet right
now find you a [ __ ] video and then
practice by yourself and do it in the
mirror like the chicks do right alright
YouTube YouTube you can dance too all
right
search basic dance moves to not look
stupid I felt stupid with an e at the
end what the for stupid
to dance with confidence not look like a
dork and I got to tell you this guy Club
dance moves for men how do not look
stiff and awkward BAM there you go
here we go a three-minute video after
this [ __ ] stupid goddamn guy tells me
about Grape Nuts standing on a [ __ ]
Mountain so I'm always just started
running naked how to dance for men it's
an asian kid with the cool hat you know
he's gonna be good there you go BAM the
name of this video is club dance moves
for men how to not look stiff and
awkward for beginner all right dude I
found that in too [ __ ] sick seconds
all right there you go there you go
you're in so just [ __ ] do that for a
while till its second goddamn nature put
a little stank on your face and you know
pump a [ __ ] couple drinks in yourself
no no no you're underage
you'll be fine to it you'll be fine just
do it
learn how did you learn how to get good
at saxophone did you sit there going you
know I know I could play saxophone but
you never did it just go out and do it
you'll be fine alright solo [ __ ] dear
bill this old house I'm a home owner
like yourself and like yourself I looked
into solar power hey not for nothing I
don't be a [ __ ] here do you have you
paid off your house because if you
haven't paid off your house you're not a
homeowner alright what you own is the
debt on the house okay I hate when
people they owe you you rent he um I um
no you don't you don't know you don't
own it until they give it to you that
good [ __ ] goddamn piece of paper
sorry and like yourself
I looked into solar power bill when I
tell you I spent over 200 hours reading
up on solar and talking to different
installers I'm telling you the truth
I had zero luck finding anything that
made sense yeah I think there's a lot of
taxes and [ __ ] there's a lot of oil and
coal kind of jockeying against that [ __ ]
the more research I did the more
discouraged I got I went in thinking
there was no way I wouldn't come out
with some type of solar panel
subsidizing the energy I use yeah now
they do this thing with The Electric
Company they used to buy back your power
now they just claim the [ __ ] that you
don't even use I hate to be cynical but
I feel like solar is useless till the
technology gets better I don't know if
you've ever followed through but I was
hoping to get an update um I don't think
it's useless
I understand anything that is gonna help
us slow down [ __ ] global warming is
gonna be an asset if you can't afford to
do it I understand I have not done it
yet I keep telling my wife I want to do
and she's like it's gonna be loud and
it's just like you know I would love to
do it I have some Spanish style not on
all the whole roof my roof is flat and
then there's a little lip of Spanish
tiles but like Tesla is allegedly coming
out with those those Spanish tiles that
are also solar-powered I mean that
[ __ ] guy is like actually addressing
what's going on and I wish there was a
way that he could [ __ ] hire coal
miners to [ __ ] work in the solar
industry so they didn't have to take
away 30% of our beautiful public parks
to continue using this [ __ ] form of
energy that is [ __ ] with the planet
that but for some reason you're not
allowed to bring it up if you do you're
crying snowflake I don't know it's it's
I have no idea and I have not read up as
nearly as much as you have I am I have
not even overheard as much as you've
probably read on it
I'll read up on it I should do it I
would love to do it
you know but I just every time I [ __ ]
go to do something I'm [ __ ] something
in my house I only tell you guys when
I'm [ __ ] deal with right now I don't
even want to [ __ ] tell you what I'm
[ __ ] deal with here have you ever
heard of roof rats roof rats evidently
we somehow some we have a crawl space
between our roof and you know you can't
stand up but it was enough that these
[ __ ] mice got up there and I would
have an exterminator come up there you
know god knows what they did in the
walls thank God they didn't chew through
any [ __ ] wires and you know so then I
got to go up there and you know get rid
of the dead mice
that's my life okay sobriety hey Billy
Bhama said I'm a 27 year old male and I
just wanted to truly say thank you for
helping me onto the wagon of sobriety
forget the past few months I've really
started listening to your podcast and
have heard you [ __ ] and moan the whole
time about being sober from drinking
this made me think to myself hey if this
can this [ __ ] can do it so can i it's
been a few weeks now and I've been clean
from drugs and alcohol and I've never
felt better yeah it's [ __ ] amazing
not living a clean lifestyle I mean at
night it sucks if that's when you get
squirrely but if you just [ __ ] push
through it and you wake up in the
morning stone sober it's it's like you
feel like you've compared to you know
being hungover and [ __ ] and I never even
[ __ ] with drugs other than alcohol
which is a drug in all fairness you feel
like an eight-year-old when you wake up
he said I don't have friends because
they're deadbeat drug addict losers so
every day at my job I list I literally
listen to eight hours of the podcast a
day see so you're learning how to take
your addictive personality and pointing
it at [ __ ] that's more positive
hopefully this positive is more positive
so in a sense you're my only friend so
thanks for that as well thanks for
helping me through these trying times
and I really look forward to maybe
seeing your set at one of your Chicago
shows in November hey you know I was
hanging out Friday night with a buddy of
mine who's been sober for nine months
and he just wanted to do it for a month
but just after a month all this [ __ ] had
even putting off all of a sudden he
started getting [ __ ] done he said I'm
gonna go two months and now he's just
staying sober he was saying just out of
superstition that I don't want to go
back to that and that's a great thing so
I'm gonna try to go September without
drinking today I have I have my big
cheat thing is I have a glass bottle of
grape Fanta that I'm going to have with
my burger and then I'm right back on the
wagon but uh pretty but I'm gonna be
eating you know eating healthy the rest
day I hate that don't care what people
say I'm heat I've been eating clean you
know
like I just I don't like that yeah you
know just clean eating been eating clean
it's like huh you don't even know what
the [ __ ] you're eating I go to these
farmers markets and you have no idea
where this [ __ ] came from there's nobody
down there playing I've heard like the
FDA basically police's like 3% of the
food you have no idea where the [ __ ]
kid came from you have no [ __ ] idea
you have no idea what it's been sprayed
with and all of that [ __ ] but it says
organic and it gets in your [ __ ] head
whoo I'm leaking [ __ ] clean you have
no [ __ ] idea unless you grew it
yourself dilemma um alright dear Billy
brown belt would you rather be forced to
eat protein bars every meal for the rest
of your life or eat one meal every four
days can I survive can I survive eating
one meal every four days I don't know if
you could survive doing that man that's
a good one no I'd rather you one meal
every four days I think I'd be more
healthy than those protein bars cuz you
don't know what the [ __ ] in those
things either you mean you flipped that
thing over like oh yeah anyway I think
it's [ __ ] overrated GNC all those
powdered [ __ ] chemicals like that
maca powder every time I put that in
there I go what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
you know the plant based protein powder
and all that it's just go go eat a
[ __ ] plant umm anyways number two all
right another dilemma um I don't want to
be Billy Clif Bar for the rest of my
[ __ ] life cuz once every four days I
could actually I could actually have
something that I liked you know chicken
and dumplings some [ __ ] like that
something really fancy let me they'll be
like having a death-row [ __ ] meal
every four days yeah that would be
tremendous as long as you I could do
that in a healthy way yeah I would do
that you get used to that quick number
two you're going to die but you can save
your life if you succeed at one of two
things
which do you have more confidence in
doing successful
having one year to study and get a
perfect score on the SATs you [ __ ]
that or come in first place in a game of
Monopoly I have one year to come in
first place in a game of Monopoly how
many games can i play
is it a monopoly tournament my playing
with a bunch of old ladies that have
been playing it since the [ __ ]
Depression and are gonna kick my ass
alright having one year to study and get
a perfect score on the SATs you know
what dude I would love to try to do that
and it would take me way more than a
year with the math all I know is that I
took a college SAT prep course
and I still got I got a three something
combined I'm not even [ __ ] lying to
you guys like I I that sounds like a
joke but I I mean boy just to study the
paper yeah I know I know
I forget what I got I got did I get a
410 or a 390 it was bad and I remember
getting laughs at my SAT score you know
that's how you know that's how I always
did I was [ __ ] made fun of myself and
I got laughs so I actually I remember I
didn't give a [ __ ] I never gave a [ __ ] I
always kinda always kind of had this
feeling that I was gonna do our writing
life you know I had an overall positive
outlook despite everything that I was
doing you don't have two years of a
language yeah y'all is [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] you know what I mean that's not
life is not about those things all right
I'm not saying don't try don't [ __ ]
try to do well on the thing and all of
that [ __ ] I'm not [ __ ] saying that
I'm just saying there's there's a
million ways to skin a cat okay how the
[ __ ] did that come about huh I'm gonna
look that one up it's more than one way
to skin a cat right there's more
one way to skin a cat origin and early
appearance is in way down east oh wow
Jesus Christ what the animala G of the
phrase this more one more than one which
you know so many times and you look
these up it's just not satisfying
so there's actually only two ways to
skin a cat while it's alive or a while
its dead well I mean you could also
start at the head you could start at the
back didn't wanna say the ass there are
two ways one one of them is you skin a
cat because you are a bad person the
other is you don't skin a cat you are a
nice or the cat never existed
the third one weight is both you skin a
cat and at the same time you don't skin
it ok this is just people right I find
your use of boiled down in this context
disturbing you knew this would this
would bring out all the [ __ ] animal
lovers right let's see if there's any
comments from the [ __ ] PETA people
PETA people PETA PETA people there's
more than one way to skin a cat is not
referring to the removal of flesh from
our feline friends but rather a phrase
that originated from the Mississippi
River region that pertains to the
preparation of a catfish oh well maybe
that's what it is I have no idea I don't
[ __ ] know anyways that's the podcast
happy Labor Day to y'all happy Labor Day
to you woo woo
I'll [ __ ] check in on you this
Thursday
hey go [ __ ] yourselves and enjoy your
day off yeah [ __ ] it